[Music]
hi and welcome to episode 180 of the
weekly Google cloud platform podcast I'm
mark and I'm here with my colleague mark
hi mark hey Mark how are you doing I
feel like spider-man mean we're we're
both pointing at each other oh we're
doing that for people who can't see
everybody awesome so what are we talking
about today well today we've got a great
interview with Jen person who actually
just recently became a cloud focused
developer advocate but used to be on the
firebase developer advocate team yep and
as such she came in to tell us a little
bit more about some of the cool recent
announcements for firebase after i/o
a little bit more I mean there's been a
couple of episodes about firebase but
it's such a wide topic you know there's
so much there yeah we actually I went
back and looked at we hadn't talked
about firebase since 18th of October
2017 so there's been a bit of stuff
coming people have been working yeah
yeah they've been up to something so
yeah that's a really cool conversation
and then after that I get to ask you a
tough question which is how do I save
money on my Google cloud platform
resources super employee everybody well
everyone I'm gonna save money people
like money turn zhuang yeah important
yeah but before we get to that yeah
we've got to talk about the cool thing
or things of the week yeah so what do
you got well the first thing I'd like to
start off with is this really cool blog
post we had just not too long ago
talking a little bit about uploading
images to cloud storage using a signed
URL oh yeah right so traditionally you'd
have like an image uploader you'd have a
service to handle that and then you'd
send it off
yep but it turns out that can be really
hard to scale yeah so this little blog
post goes through some of the details of
how you can generate a signed URL
specifically for the user yet send it to
cloud storage which handles a lot of
storage yeah more than a few couple of
little bits yeah millions billions and
then generates that signed URL and you
give it to your app it allows them to
upload that directly to cloud storage so
there's no middle person needed so you
can just kind of upload the file and
then you're good to go so it's actually
a really really cool way to remove an
unnecessary component of file uploading
right now you can handle that with your
stuff you handle it directly with cloud
storage and it's secure super easy
secure you know that side you are
obviously expires relatively you can
tell when to expire makes the process a
lot easier and really I think it's about
again focusing on the actual application
yep as opposed to the infrastructure
nice fantastic well we've got a blog
post and a matching solution for build
your own event source system using cloud
spanner I like this a lot this is
basically the example they use here is
something like an e-commerce system
where say like a customer add something
to a cart and then they click checkout
or then they have payment processing and
you want to track all the events all the
way through that flow but then you want
to do stuff based on that events so the
whole solution takes you through how you
can use spanner to do that how you can
build like a polling system to update
other systems about when that happens so
that you could take that data and say
like push it into bigquery or put into
pub/sub or do all sorts of other
interesting things that you could keep
like historical records and all that
kind of stuff so we'll have a link in
the show notes so you can check that out
if that's the sort of thing that you
might be interested in I think it's cool
right I mean like when you design a site
like that you might be focused very much
on how people use it yeah but then you
actually have to analyze what's going on
where any triggers are happening and
then eventually like how do we take that
information and do something with it
exactly super cool well another cool
thing that I recently discovered I
actually have no idea when this happened
it may have been you know today it may
have been a month ago it may have been a
long time ago but it turns out the
Google Cloud I think it's called cloud
console which is a Google mobile app
yeah the mobile app got it on Android
and iPhone or iOS I should say that
actually has the ability to get cloud
shell in it as well
Oh neat so we were talking not too long
ago about how kind of cool cloud shell
is and it gives you this kind of safe
workspace you can play around with and
it gives you the g-cloud command line
tool so you can you know integrate with
all the other Google cloud processes but
now you can have that from your phone so
I mean like there's been a couple of
cases where I've been away on holiday or
something of that nature and then
someone's like oh hey the servers down
and this kind of this and first of all
serverless second of all you still have
to go in and do something rip and being
able to have the power of the honestly
just the g-cloud command line from your
phone like that's I knew you could SSH
into a GC instance on your phone I did
not know that you could use cloud show
that's pretty awesome yeah I mean now
you don't like you could probably set up
like a bastion somewhere and then just
put G cloud on it and use that as a
proxy but now you don't even need your
duniya you just have it straight from
your phone there's a maze that is
amazing fantastic lost this is an
interesting article it's called Google
cloud networking in depth
load-balancing deconstructed so I think
this actually has two really interesting
things to it that you probably should be
interested in one if you're ever like
how does Google cloud do networking how
do the things work behind the scenes
this is a really good article too but if
you were also kind of looking at it from
the perspective of which load balancing
solution should I be using for the
things that I want to do this also has a
really nice comprehensive summary there
too so it goes through a network load
balancing it goes through global load
balancing some of the things that we do
on the edge for security how we optimize
for latency with CND's and things like
that different network tiers stuff like
that it's a really nice overview of the
things we do on the networking space I
think we see a lot of people who are
maybe they come to the cloud and they
don't realize how different it is from
your traditional networking setup
especially people who have been working
in data center for a long time yep and
so I mean the more content we see like
this I think there's actually a series
of deep dives on the blog that go into
different components this one about load
balancing specifically but like there's
so much out there that kind of like
helps people understand what the cloud
really is different yeah you know for
the better I'd like to say yeah but at
the very least like we need more
resources for people to get that access
and understand hey this is how it works
yeah absolutely super cool awesome well
why don't we go chat with Jen sounds
good let's go do it okay everyone we're
super excited to have Jen person with us
here today a cloud developer advocate
Jen tell us a little bit about yourself
and what you do well thank you as you
said I am a cloud developer advocate as
of starting this week prior to that I
was a firebase developer advocate and I
also made some courses around firebase
in partnership with Udacity so I do a
little of traveling giving talks I do a
lot of recording videos do some blogs
answer a bunch of people's questions on
Stack Overflow and also answer some
questions on Twitter so if you're in the
firebase community I've probably
answered your question once or twice
awesome well very excited to have you on
the cloud developer advocate team and
since we have you now on the cloud
developer team I think now we should
just talk you about firebase is a
firebase expert yeah we have that there
we go
so yeah Jen thank you for for coming to
talk to us about firebase we have done I
went had a look at one two three four
was s at four and a half because
firestore sort of crosses boundaries
first questions
tell us about firestorm
yes but if people haven't caught any of
the four and a half episodes previously
can you give us a little overview of
firebase what does it do what's the cool
stuff about it yeah so firebase is a
suite of products to help you build your
app and grow your user base I sort of
think of it as the application the
client side of Google Cloud so you know
basically any solution you could need in
your app like be it authentic Asian or
data storage or dynamic links all sorts
of things analytics all available
one-stop shop within firebase and it is
cross-platform for iOS Android web we
also have C++ unity SDK is basically
covering all of the client SDKs as well
as a big server-side offering so we're
basically trying to solve all of your
development problems just the whole
front back the middle everything I don't
even know what I have a Google cloud
anymore
no idea it just replace the whole thing
well that's really interesting point
right because if firebase offers a lot
of these more client facing things but
it does offer some database side of
things right some more of the server end
but you can also use firebase the client
side to integrate with any of the GCP
back-end stuff right right yes so a lot
of times we get questions like what is
the difference between firebase and
Google cloud and it's not so much that
there a difference there's sort of if
it's a Venn diagram firebase is somewhat
overlapping for the most part with
Google cloud so they share a lot of the
same services but the firebase side
really is developed to be for
client-side developers for the most part
to make your job easier where Google
cloud is generally speaking more
enterprise and it does seem like
firebase is more like I've heard it
referred to as like back into the
service or maybe serverless would that
be accurate yeah yeah so we have a whole
bunch of features that our back-end as a
service we also have a lot of growth
features as well what do you mean by
growth features oh well I'm glad you
asked so after your app is built you
need a way to connect with your users
and sort of expand that user base so
that could be through notifications or
through a
testing you can use remote config which
allows you to change some details about
how your app works or appears so you
couldn't try different configurations
and see which ones your users liked
better and really just optimize your app
and a lot of times we'll have a good
idea but how do you really hone it and
make it exactly what your users want our
growth features help you do that
so it's this you know there's the suite
of tools that kind of help you design
all these things and you know those old
podcast episodes I talked about firebase
go into a lot of details what's new with
firebase right what have we seen
especially with i/o just recently last
month what's kind of new and cool with
it yeah I went back and looked at our
last episode was back in 2017 so I
assume some new stuff has come out
probably at least a thing yeah you know
a couple things so one of the things
that's really interesting about how
firebase has been developing is that
when we first started we just were
growing and growing and adding all these
different products and now what I see
firebase doing is really maturing and
adding to those different products that
we already have and making them really
suit the developers based on the
feedback that we're getting from you so
in terms of existing products things
we've added to them for a cloud
firestore which is our second database
offering it's also no sequel like the
real time database and is built of
collections of documents it's no longer
in beta I know that that was a deterrent
for some developers you're worried about
do I really want to push this to
production if it's something in beta
well it's not anymore so it's really a
mature product really excited about how
it's been working I absolutely love how
it solves problems that I faced in the
past with no sequel and very recently we
just added collection group queries so
prior to that you could not make a
specific query that spanned across
different sub collections at different
documents so sub collections were seen
as just completely separate entities
from one another but now you can query
and it'll pull the key from every sub
collection so very cool so is this kind
of like a newer version of the real time
database
yeah you know I would say that that's
the simplest explanation but we are
still definitely supporting the real
type database the real-time nature of it
is just been really helpful for a lot of
scenarios and so it's still gonna be
there and it still may be suited best
for certain situations for instance if
you are doing a whole lot of writes very
quickly the real-time database might be
a better solution for you so things like
in games but I see cloud firestore as
the next step because it adds stronger
querying better querying power a
structure that it makes more sense to
mirror your application basically all
the answers to the questions that people
had about real-time database and it has
kind of a broad use case like you said
for a lot of people since we were
actually the beginning just talking
about well you can actually get
firestore through GCP rather than
through four you can do it through both
firebase or through GCP again depending
on your use case yeah exactly and that
actually means that if you're starting
with a very small team and you're
building an application and then it
becomes extremely popular switching over
to Google cloud is a breeze I don't
think we've ever actually talked about
that on any of the previous episodes
because there's a really nice graduation
path I think you know as you go in
firebase and then if you wanted to add
extra features into GCP can you talk a
little about that yeah sure so whenever
you create a firebase project it's also
a google cloud project which enables you
to implement any of the Google Cloud
api's right from the Google Cloud
console and there is also as you pointed
out some overlapping features like a
cloud firestore like cloud storage which
is available for specifically for
firebase but it's the same cloud storage
underneath that we used in Google cloud
and recently we added identity platform
so now we have auth features in cloud
that add on to the firebase off features
and really are suited for those
enterprise situations and switching over
is really simple because you already
have your project you don't have to
worry about trying to link projects
together so it might be a good example
that someone kind of started with
firebase and then they
a little bit more and then they wanted
to build in some more GCP projects as
GCP products but it might also go the
other way where you're using GCP
products and you want to add a mobile
app or something like that and it would
make just as much sense to kind of
create that fire based project and go
off of that right yeah absolutely and if
you have an existing Google cloud
project you can import it into firebase
so yeah you can definitely go either way
and there are situations where as you
pointed out if you want to build a
client app that would make sense and a
lot of times we will be using cloud
api's even when you're using firebase so
if you want to do some sort of
translation server-side or something
like that we would use Google clouds for
that very cool you mentioned one thing
in passing this I don't know it's always
my favorite feature of firebase is a
firebase auth and like having built out
on our websites for 20 years like not
having to build an authentication scheme
it seems really cool but it looks like
you've had some improvements in the last
couple years on that - yeah in the last
couple of years we've added several new
ways to authenticate we added phone off
we added email link auth so rather than
having an email and password you can
send an email link and you can click on
it in your email we've added different
email actions so in the console you can
decide like what is the message that you
want your clients to get when they get
say an email to verify or you can change
that from the client as well and our
latest identity providers that we've
added our Microsoft and Yahoo la and now
we're going to be using a generic oo
auth - provider sign in so going forward
it's going to be even easier to add
different providers you may have noticed
in the past each provider maybe has a
little bit different way that it works
you need to log in say with Facebook and
then they have their own portal and then
you have to take that information and
use it to log in to firebase but now
with that o2 provider sign in being
generic it basically just pops up a web
window and they all work the same and
that's gonna make a lot easier for us to
to add more providers so hopefully we'll
have more providers going forward
quicker no more having to implement
reset your password functionality don't
build your own off
just don't don't there's a very small
set of use cases where you need to foot
otherwise man you just don't yeah you
know one time I watched this sort of how
it's made show on YouTube about making
soy sauce and soy sauce is basically
water and salt and soy beans right so
you could theoretically make your own
soy sauce but wouldn't you rather just
make dinner that's kind of how I think
about it is like yes you can spend all
of your development time making this
very complex thing like handling off or
you could make what you went out to make
the application that you wanted to make
and leave that to us because we have all
this experience with it I feel that way
about any cooking whatsoever like I
could make this bowl of cereal but
wouldn't I rather have someone make the
bowl of cereal I sadly would excellent
one thing I actually I've been also
dying to talk about on the podcast but
we haven't had it just haven't had a
chance unfortunately ml kit is super
interesting tell us more about that I
think it's fascinating yeah so what ml
kit does is it provides you a simplified
way to use machine learning on your
clients app or on the server and we have
all sorts of different ml features that
we're slowly adding to it and so the
benefit of using ml kit is that we have
with on-device ml features you are able
to use them even if you don't have
internet access so it leads to a much
quicker experience we're able to do
things like if you have a video and
you're just filming in the moment you
could do real-time text recognition or
face detection because it's right there
on the device so it's super fast and if
you need something a little more
powerful you could still use the cloud
side and it's done simply through our
SDK so right now for an ml kit
Wow it's growing so fast I swear there's
a new feature every week I actually had
to look it up to make sure I got them
all in terms of natural language we have
identifying language of text we have
Translate and we also have added smart
apply we have a lot of cloud vision
features including recognizing text
detecting faces including landmarks on
the face so not just detecting a square
of a face but like where's the nose
where the eyes helps you make all those
fun filters scanning barcodes which is
super popular labeling images detecting
and tracking objects which we recently
added and recognizing popular landmarks
and we also added Auto ml vision edge so
if you have a custom auto ml model you
can access it right on your device so
you can see that's another way that
there's an overlap between google cloud
and firebase and if you really need a
customized model you can use tensorflow
Lite you can run your tensorflow lite
model through ml kit so it's pretty much
ml kit is the way to use any ml
technology with your mobile / web /
whatever app right with your iOS and
Android app yep our goal I think it's
just to cover any in all scenarios and
we're really excited to see how people
are going to be using it and we also
have a Google Group so if you want to
join that and follow along and see how
other people are using ml kit we'd love
to see how you're using it as well I'm
just kind of excited about having smart
reply as a service I'm trying to think
of like wonderfully horrible things
we're gonna get to the point where you
don't need to even be there you don't
need to respond to anything and you'll
still be responding yeah right your ml
will kind of figure you out as a person
which is a scary thought but then after
that you're like the infinite
convenience I have I can have my phone
order my cereal for me in the morning
and have to do nothing yes assuming we
build the cereal service first I don't
need to do podcast hosting anymore in
Auto mm-hmm wait wait no we shouldn't
explore this concept I need this job
and you also before talking before the
podcast we were talking about cloud
functions as well we did do a previous
episode I think that was the last one
yeah it was in like 2017 but I'm sure
cloud functions have also come a long
way since then yeah yeah cloud functions
for firebase are no longer in beta
so yeah these were the two big pushes
that we had cloud fire storm cloud
functions and getting those out of beta
into BGA has been really great so we are
continuing to add different types of
triggers I'm trying to guess which ones
have been added since the previous
guessing at production launch this seems
like a good idea
it'll be fine yeah so let's see we have
now a crashlytics trigger so that's cool
if you have some sort of crash you can
trigger our function and then you could
use that function to say send a
notification to slack or something like
that and my favorite we now have
scheduled functions big requests there
you can now schedule your functions to
run at a specific time and repeat and we
have a new emulator that can run your
functions right on your device without
touching your live code and it also
emulates all sorts of different things
in your app like if you're using cloud
firestore you can basically have a whole
ecosystem working right from your device
and not worry about accessing the
external live code and you can test it
out Onis is that using the like the
firebase command-line utility or
something to set that up yeah yeah the
command-line utility that was like no no
you just go firebase you just so like a
common use case for some people might be
setting up their app hooking into a fire
store for their database and then when
some event happens or when they upload a
certain amount of data to fire store and
then triggers a function does a little
bit of processing on it and then maybe
puts it back in or like you said sends a
notification the possibilities are
probably endless there oh yes definitely
and it's great because it also connects
with all sorts of third-party services
as well so it's not just exclusively
within the Google cloud environment
you're able to incorporate whatever
third-party services you need and for
now until we add different types of
authentication it's also a way you could
handle custom off like I know in our
functions samples github repo we have an
example of logging in with Instagram and
what else we have a github one but I
could just log in with github yeah it
had to take a look so yeah we actually
have a repo full of cloud function
samples if
you want some ideas about how you could
use them cool we can put a link to that
in the show notes I'd love to know
what's been the most interesting or
strange thing you've seen somebody build
with firebase that's a great question oh
okay so when I was at a hackathon so you
know you're looking at having a really
limited amount of time right now in
terms of deploying cloud functions of
firebase you do that from the command
line interface but what they did is
basically make a website where you can
just type your JavaScript code right
into it and it deploys it automatically
for you and the way that it worked was
actually just taking the actual chunks
of your code and turning them into
strings and putting them into the
database and that would trigger a
function that then reassembled it and
made that into a cloud function I just
thought it was a really fascinating
implementation there's no way that could
be abused not any code anyway I mean
everybody yeah so I thought that was
pretty cool that is very cool so you'd
also you know we're coming off of the IO
and the next conference season for
Google you gave a talk at i/o right yeah
so I gave a talk with cat Fang and Mike
McDonald and Frank van poppelen we did
our 0-2 app live coding talk this is
something that we've done at several
events but this time we used a brand new
application so what basically happens is
one of us is talking while the other
three of us are coding on three
different platforms and it is wild it is
amazing that anything ever works and we
really are coding it and deploying it
live have you practiced it before or are
you doing it all fresh can you tell us
yeah with this particular app because we
had just built it is it bad to say we
probably practiced it like two full
times you know like more times than I
promised on our own tried to make sure
that our component was working but to
bring it all together probably only
happened a couple of times yeah I mean
on one live demo as day
just enough but three live coding
sessions happening on stage seems
reasonable right I guess what I tell
myself is if I make a mistake at least
two thirds of the people are probably
looking somewhere else that's a good
point
oh so all three people's screen are up
on the stage at the same time so
everyone can see everything exactly so
it looks like the Brady Bunch
just got different screens all going at
once that's not si did it work for the
most part I will say that when I started
my code and I implemented off when I
went to login it just gave me like error
code two and I was like great great this
is great
I had this documentation that might
explain so then fortunately it was my
turn to talk and puff came over and he
was able to look at my code while I was
like I had slides up so you couldn't see
it and what happened was we were
hardwired for internet because that's
supposed to be faster but the internet
they connected me to the ethernet cord
didn't actually work so we just had to
connect to the Wi-Fi but yeah that was
the only slip-up that's great hashtag
conference problems yeah absolutely so
if people want to learn more about
firebase what's your favorite resource
with people being able to do that well
let's see I really do absolutely love
our guides which you can find on our
website
firebase google.com but what I've found
most useful is our quick starts which
are also linked there but sometimes when
I'm just reading a description of
something I'm like okay what does this
actually look like so if you go over to
the quick starts you could see how all
those features work separately and
together and you can see it in an app
that actually works and that helps it
make a lot more sense so I hear that you
run a program called fire casts what is
a fire cast so a fire cast is sort of
like a generally brief we like to have
them less than 10 minutes video where we
do some screen casting and we do some
maybe head shots with maybe some nice
diagrams where we explain something in
firebase and that could be like a
specific feature and getting started
with it that could be a problem and
showing you how firebase can help you
solve it just a little bit of an
Meishan not quite as big as a tutorial
altogether but just a little bit to get
you started also sounds like a good
resource for learning more about
firebase yes definitely not that the
previous question was leading in any way
so how do you determine what topics you
want to have on the fire cast it sounds
like you have a pretty diverse set of
things that you talk about oh yeah yeah
if you check it out we have different
fire casts for almost every single
product on all of our platforms
personally when it comes to making new
fire casts I take a look at the kind of
questions that I'm getting so that's why
those are so important I was running a
show called ask firebase up until
recently and so people will use the
hashtag ask firebase on social media and
I basically take all of those questions
and look at them and determine which
ones work best on the show but I also
aggregate them I look at what are the
common themes that I'm seeing here is
there a problem that a video could
easily solve so I do it based on the
kind of questions people ask so keep
those questions coming even though I
can't answer everyone directly it does
help determine where the direction that
our product goes have there been any
like recent insights that you've gotten
from the ask firebase that have kind of
been surprising oh that's a good
question
thank you it's like you know what you're
doing it's weird it's like I'm a host or
something yeah just kidding I have no
idea what I'm doing
well I guess I'll say broadly I learn a
lot about how our products work just
from ask firebase so there are specific
products with in firebase that I focus
most of my time on and a lot of times
when I have a guest coming on ask
firebase they work on a product that I'm
not so familiar with so it gives me a
chance to get those questions answered
and learn some stuff along the way well
I think that's the beautiful part about
being in developer relations is that
when you're working with these products
internally you think about X Y & Z but
then you hear from people who are using
them you're like I never thought of
using it like J like that's crazy to me
but let's talk about let's figure it out
and let's kind of glean insights from
that yeah
I always have in my mind how I think I
would use something but seeing how our
developers use it it's very different so
now I want to know now that you've
joined the cloud team are we gonna
expect similar types of media content
coming from you on the cloud side can
you talk about that yet or is it a
secret
oh no yeah I'm definitely going to be
continuing to make video content because
it's my absolute favorite thing so I
think there's gonna be a whole lot more
of that because I'm going to have more
time to dedicate to it so while I have
change teams definitely still see my
face around a lot we're gonna look for a
hashtag ask cloud could be a good write
that one down
I'll take credit for it don't tempt me
yeah you know what I can just put out
the hashtag and I'll set up a
spreadsheet so I can start getting those
questions and we'll just see if people
ask enough questions for us to start a
show did you hear that listeners the
onus is on you yeah it's all up to them
who are listening right now like you can
make this a reality we just need you to
ask a lot of relevant questions
fantastic well we are coming up on time
a little bit but before we finish up is
there anything that we missed or
something you want to make sure you plug
or just things that people should know
about before we finish up today so
anyone who listens to this podcast has
probably already figured out that Google
cloud is huge and encompasses all sorts
of different products and even as
someone who works here I can find it
confusing sometimes trying to get to the
right resource so by all means if you
have the possibility to reach out to
somebody who works on Google cloud or
works on firebase they may be able to
point you in the right direction
they might know where that resources
that you're looking for so we really do
have some great documentation out there
but sometimes finding the exact solution
you're looking for is a little harder
because maybe you'll word it a little
differently when you're searching for it
so yeah going back to asking questions
very important yeah I mean I think there
are so many different products and even
you know people come up to us
occasionally and they're like oh you're
working cloud so you know about this
there's like no don't I mean a lot of
times there's so much stuff here it just
sounds like us Jen hashtag ask Jen I
will also take credit for that if you
choose to use it
sorry I'm just trying to
put my hooks and everything no you got
that it's totally your idea so should I
send the questions your way then yes you
should you send it to mark yes
yeah mark can answer the other mark
we're pointing I know it doesn't work as
well but it's like a spider-man comic
all right whoa whoa Jen thank you so
much for coming on the podcast and
telling is all about firebase today
thank you Mark and Mark you're welcome
thanks Jen thanks all right thanks so
much to Jen for coming in it was super
super awesome to hear about all the cool
firebase things and now that she's on
the cloud team yep we'll hear about many
awesome cloud things as well yep sounds
great I'm looking forward to all the new
content she's gonna produce that's gonna
be super cool yeah so let's get stuck in
our question of the week where I get to
ask the tough questions um what I want
to know is how do I save money on my
Google cloud platform resources just
across all of them can you solve all
those problems just every resource well
the first thing you do is just shut them
all down you will not spend anything if
you don't use anything right the nice
advantage of the cloud it turns out that
is does not work for most people so a
more realistic approach is to actually
try to figure out what you have that's
up and running that you're paying for
that you're not really using okay and so
there was a super cool talk at next
that's on YouTube and we'll have a link
in the description below that talks a
little bit about how to automate cost
optimization toolings basically by
scanning your resources for things
you're not using that you are paying for
and then shutting them down you can
write that using cloud functions pretty
quickly right and then it just goes into
it so in the talk they talked a little
bit about what's the example they give
looking at like so external IP addresses
I don't know if you knew this yeah but
you don't pay for them when they're
attached to a resource but you do pay
for them if they're not so there it is
and so if you have an external IP
address has been sitting around for 30
days there's a pretty good chance you
may not need it of course that'll beat
up to your business logic if you
actually want it or not but if you're
not saving those for anything you can
actually write this cool function
that'll go scan all your IP addresses
see which ones haven't been used in a
while and then shut them off put that on
like a cloud scheduler job maybe yeah
and then you've kind of got this great
system to automatically scan for it and
delete it saving you a little bit money
so you can do that with external IP
addresses the talk also shows doing that
with persistent disks that haven't been
used any resources any you know compute
in
load balancers that might be sitting
around doing nothing anything there's so
many different resources that especially
for large organizations like you can get
lost
in just the sheer number of projects you
have right so check the talk out it's
super cool it gives some practical
examples in actual code that you can run
very cool but then like it should enable
people to take a look at it and say
where else can I might be wasting
resources yes you could even just send
reports you could do email reports
that's just neat yeah I mean like yeah
once you once your world is your oyster
exactly if you want to email somebody
set up a dashboard automatically delete
them yep it doesn't matter
awesome fantastic so mark what do you up
to what cool things are you doing well
next week I am gone I'm disappearing
into the ether for a week and then after
that I will be in New York oh yeah and
then coming up I'll be going down to LA
so a little bit of traveling you know
generally I like to stay where I am okay
but you know moving around a little bit
what about yourself I will be at Tokyo
next presenting I'll be doing some stuff
at the games and apps inside event right
with Tokyo next so unsurprisingly I will
be talking about IKONOS
and being around and talk about games
and stuff mark talking about it go knows
who you why would that hey I have no
idea I would like what if you just did
like a live coding for your talk at next
right because you do the live streaming
for coding right I do and do you think
they would approve it if you did that as
a session
I don't know how interesting I mean
hopefully people I don't know I think
it'd be kind of cool yeah so actually if
you are interested usually about once a
week I live stream on Twitch that's
something I do usually if I'm not
traveling anyway so you can follow me on
twitch TV slash mark Mandal or you can
just type of look for me on youtube as
well and I'll do a live streaming of
development of on reconnaissance I do
that that fairly regularly so if you're
like well I wonder how Mark thinks and
how much does he actually talk to
himself and how often does his dog bug
him and you have an avenue for finding
out - the dog part that might make for a
really cool next session I mean the dog
would be fine but I'm sure there'd be
rules against bringing a dog if Maddie
Chen can bring on her hamster I think it
was Dara io talk then I think I can
bring my dog on stage you could bring
the dog you could bring the audience
into the whole thing it could be like a
an actual live coding session there you
go it's just me sitting there being like
so why isn't this working you have 45
minutes of me just sitting there like
cursing at my computer it turns out just
make for entertaining television anyway
I'll tell you what if people are
interested in me doing that live on
stage let me know I'd be happy to do
that be fun fantastic well mark thank
you for joining me on the episode of the
podcast this week always good to chat
with you mark and thank you all for
listening and we'll see you all next
week see ya
[Music]
[Music]
you
you